clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic
merci à bonn toi
mes chers compatriotes nous sommes en
guerre non je déconne on n'est pas en
guerre
je suis comme vous je suis je suis en
confinement je suis en télétravail
du coup j'ai pas un romain j'ai pas mon
studio j'ai pas mon matériel habituel
évidemment encore plus que d'habitude
il est hors de question que je vous
laisse tomber donc je vais vous faire un
d'été c'est quand même et je vais vous
faire un dtc en mode inception endettés
c'est sur le confinement
d'abord avons commencé gardez bien en
tête que on en apprend tous les jours
sur le virus sur l'épidémie de la
situation elle évolue de jour en jour
d'heure en heure même pratiquement ce
qui veut dire que ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui au moment où je vous parle
ce sera pas forcément vrai demain donc
le premier conseil que je vous donne
c'est aller vous renseigner sur des
sites d'infos fable et surtout des sites
d'info qui sont mis à jour en temps réel
pour ça parce que je vais faire parce
que je suis sympa je vais vous mettre
dans la barre de description des sites
fiables qui sont mis à jour le plus
fraîchement possible comme ça vous aurez
des sources d'infos consultez
régulièrement
et puis aussi la plateforme téléphonique
spéciale coronavirus avec un numéro vert
auquel vous pouvez poser vos questions
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
c'est au 0 800 130 000
voilà ceci étant dit on va pouvoir faire
le tour du confinement en cette question
à quoi ça sert le confinement
alors oui ça l'art est une question
combien ça mais en fait pas du tout ça
permet déjà dans un premier temps de
poser les principes de battes et le
premier set quand on veut endiguer une
épidémie il faut pas penser de façon
individuelle
il faut pas se dire parce que je fais là
c'est pour pas me contaminer mois
le but c'est d'empêcher le virus de
circuler pour que ils n'atteignent pas
les plus vulnérables ceux qui pourraient
en mourir pour que le système de santé
reste à peu près à flot pour pouvoir
s'occuper du nombre de malades qui
arrivent pour pâques et un pic violent
et pour que l'épidémie finisse par
s'éteindre
et comme en l'occurrence le virus qui se
transmettent d'être humain à être humain
directement il n'est pas là dans l'air
en train de flotter les seuls moyens de
l'empêcher de se propager c'est un de
limiter au maximum le nombre de
personnes qu'on croise chaque jour donc
de rester chez soi pour être clair et de
faire baisser le plus possible les
risques de contamination entre les gens
qui se croisent quand même parce qu'il y
en a ça c'est les gestes barrière
distances de sécurité d'un mètre au
minimum entre les gens on se serre pas
la main se fait pas de bisou on évite de
se tripoter s'ils ont tout ce qu'on
éternue on éternue ou tousse dans son
coude
histoire de pas se contaminer les mains
et de mettre du virus partout après
quand on se sert d'un mouchoir on prend
un mouchoir jetable et on le jette
juste après descoings peu et le plus
souvent possible
on se lave les mains avec de l'eau et du
savon si on n'en a pas on prend gel
hydroalcoolique
voilà tout ça vous connaissez maintenant
mais ça ça fait aussi partie du boulot
au passage je vous remet un petit tuto
dans la description de la vidéo qui va
vous montrer comment on se lave vraiment
les mains de façon efficace parce que ça
a l'air évident comme ça mais en vrai
n'allait pas tout le monde le
confinement est ce que ça marche
vraiment alors oui ça marche ça marche
vraiment pour la partie théorique ce que
je vais faire c'est que je vais vous
mettre dans la description de la vidéo
un lien vers un poste de david loire de
sciences étonnante qui explique ça
extrêmement bien je pense que tous vous
avez un petit peu de temps pour l'iran
genou en substance pour vous résumer un
petit peu il explique que tout dépend de
trois paramètres la durée pendant
laquelle on est contagieux le nombre de
personnes avec lesquelles on est en
contact chaque jour et la probabilité
selon laquelle un contact entre une
personne saine et une personne infectée
débouche sur une contamination
ensuite ils montrent comment on peut
très efficacement faire baisser les
chiffres en agissant sur les deux seuls
paramètres qu'on maîtrise un petit peu
le nombre de personnes qu'on brasse
chaque jour qu'on peut faire baisser en
restant chez soi et la probabilité de
contamination qu'on peut faire mais
c'est en adoptant les gestes barrière
vraiment aller lire c'est hyper claire
et du gardien expliqué et puis en
pratique on a maintenant un petit peu de
recul et on a les ans de la chine et de
l'italie qui ont vu les cours et les
chiffres de nombre de comptes
ni baisers après le confinement donc on
sait que ça fonctionne
alors attention ça marche pas forcément
tout de suite là un délai d'incubation
qui peut aller jusqu'à 14 jours ce qui
veut dire qu il ya des gens qui ont été
contaminées avant les mesures de
confinement qui vont déclarer la maladie
qui vont avoir des seins tôt là dans les
jours qui viennent
donc la cour de continuer à monter un
petit peu mais au bout d'un moment ça va
se calmer et ça a commencé à descendre
je sais quoi si je suis malade alors
d'appeler leur café lire si vous avez
des signes qui vous font penser que
peut-être vous avez le coronavirus genre
en gros si vous avez la chaîne
si vous toussez voir éventuellement si
vous avez mal à la gorge vous appelez
votre médecin traitant vous y allez pas
vous l'appelez a priori pourra gérer sa
honte et les consultations comme dit
c'est à dire une consultation au
téléphone ou par vidéo avec votre
smartphone par contre vous n'appelez le
15 ça ça a changé depuis le début que si
vous avez fait un malaise ou si vous
avez des difficultés respiratoires après
vous pouvez aussi avoir un autre
problème de santé car rien à voir avec
le corps d'un virus pouvait avoir une à
une intoxication alimentaire une entorse
un problème cardiaque quoique se balade
dans ces cas là vous faites comme
d'habitude mes petits conseils passer un
coup de fil a donc quand même pour être
sûr que c'est pas le feu et que vous
allez pouvoir être pris dans des bonnes
conditions
est-ce qu'on va mourir de faim si ça
dure longtemps alors pour être très
clair par rapport aux magasins et aux
magasins d'alimentation puisque c'est
sur tout ça qu'on parle il n'y a pas de
problème de livraison les transporteurs
circuit les produits circulent la seule
raison pour laquelle les rayons sont
vides
c'est parce que les gens achètent
beaucoup beaucoup plus de produits que
d'habitude alors éviter d'aller au
supermarché tous les jours c'est à dire
prendre pour une semaine ok ça s'est
passé pas une bêtise et parce que ça
évite de multiplier le nombre de sorties
par contre je stockais pas pour un mois
pour deux mois pour six mois
c'est un appel parce que vous avez pas
besoin de 50 kilos de coquilles n vous
avez pas besoin de 30 packs d'eau par
contre si vous achetez tout ça elle vous
êtes plusieurs à terre il ya des gens
qui en ont
besoin et qu'ils n'en auront pas donc
faites vos courses comme d'habitude fait
pas des stocks de coûts mais du coup
est-ce que ça va durer longtemps
alors la seule vraie réponse à cette
question c'est bon c'est pas le
confinement pour l'instant c'est quinze
jours donc jusqu'à fin mars
il ya pas mal de raisons de penser que
ça va être prolongée de quinze voire 30
jours mais en vrai pour l'instant rien
d'officiel
cela dépend de la façon dont les choses
vont évoluer de la façon dont nous les
chiffres du nombre de contaminés vont
évoluer la façon dont les mesures ont
déjà été prises vont être efficace sur
l'épidémie et devant la curée de
l'épidémie dans des mêmes c'est
compliqué aussi à des experts qui disent
qu'en général ce genre d'épidémie ça
dure de trois mois donc ça nous amène à
mai juin maximum le mal ça se tasse avec
les beaux jours
il ya d'autres experts qui disent que là
on n'est pas du tout sûr que ce soit le
cadre pas s'y fier avec les annonces
qu'on a eu ces derniers jours là on a
l'impression que le comité scientifique
sur lequel le gouvernement s'appuie a
l'air de penser que effectivement pour
juin ça devrait dans le creux de la
vague ou voir terminer mais ça c'est des
projections des spéculations en vrai on
ne sait pas c'est les chiffres qui vont
parler beaucoup n'en sera plus dans les
jours et les semaines qui viennent mais
en gros il ya trois scénarios soit
l'épidémie élimine eu elle s'arrête et
on n'aura plus soit elle diminue elle
s'arrête il peut y avoir une deuxième
vague voire une troisième vague qui
arrive dans les semaines qui suivent
soit l'épidémie elle diminue elle
s'arrête
et puis elle devient saisonnière comme
la grippe aujourd'hui on n'en sait rien
donc je sers à rien de s qu'on va finir
par trouver un traitement alors
recherche allons chercher à beaucoup
beaucoup de monde qui cherche vous
doutez bien mais ça prend énormément de
temps à trouver le traitement déjà et
puis à avoir les autorisations de
l'utiliser ensuite tenir la turquie les
biens efficace qui fait pas de mal et
c'est tout ça c'est très long du coup
c'est pas du tout impossible que
le temps qu'on trouve l'épidémie se soit
déjà arrêté daily mail et c'est pareil
pour les vaccins là il ya des études qui
sont faits sur des patients qui sont
très positives aux états unis on pense
que si ça continue à bien se passer si
ça se confirme l'efficacité
peut-être que dans les semaines ou les
mois qui viennent ça pourra commente
commencé à être utilisée par contre pour
être commercialisé ce sera pas avant
début 2011 21 donc voyez tout ça c'est
très long au pire on va dire ben on sera
à paris si didier revient vous je fais
quoi si je vis mal le confinement a
alors ça c'est la grande question face
elles les grandes questions parce que en
vrai ça dépend de pourquoi vous le vivez
râle de confinement alors si c'est parce
que vous êtes confiné avec des gens avec
qui ça se passe pas très bien fait vous
voyez ce que je veux dire bon je vais
pas pouvoir grand chose pour vous à part
peut-être vous souhaiter bon courage
et puis et en talons vous rappeler qu'
on est dans une espèce d'union sacrée de
d'union nationale de combat contre un
virus et c'est que peut-être là c'est le
moment de se dire mais toutes les
histoires de côté là et puis on verra ça
une fois que une fois que ce sera
terminé
c'est pas forcément si facile que ça
mais bon le confinement avec des
personnes violentes peut être dramatique
si vous en êtes victime ou si vous êtes
témoin vous pouvez et vous devez faire
quelque chose alors pour les parents
parce que ça peut être compliqué aussi
d'avoir des enfants à la maison sans
pouvoir les faire sortir forcément etc
ça peut être compliqué ben ya des choses
qui se font sur internet jeux
on va vous le dire à chaque fois mais je
vous mets delio rossi dans la
description de vidéos alors si au
contraire vous visez mal le confinement
parce que vous êtes confiné tout seul ou
tout seul ça peut arriver à des gens
très bien là ce que je fais dans un
premier temps c'est que je vais vous
renvoyer vers les vidéos sur les crises
d'angoissé et sur la solitude
il ya plein de conseils qui vont pouvoir
s'adapter aussi à la situation
aujourd'hui
évidemment il faut pas tenir compte de
camp jeudi sortie à faire un tour ou
voir ses potes etc
même si on peut un peu sortir quand même
pour l'instant on a encore le droit
d'aller courir par exemple et sa basse
si vous avez envie si vous pouvez et ses
terrasses est quelque chose qui peut
vous faire du bien
sinon on faire du sport derrière c'est
cool aussi et puis vous pouvez pas voir
vos amis vos proches en vrai mais vous
pouvez faire des styles des feuilles
style juste des coups de fil mais à
l'image c'est quand même pas mal surtout
la règle c'est si vous vivez mal votre
confinement dit le reste est pas tout
seuls dans votre coin avec votre sommes
dit le parler avec vos amis parler avec
vos proches à tout gagner mais ça va
vous faire du bien
pour le reste comme jeudi un petit peu
dans ces deux fameuses vidéos les
activités qui stimulent l'intellect ça a
tendance à endormir tout le côté
émotionnel tout le côté angoua cet état
donc ça c'est déjà pas mal et pour les
activités créatives c'est satisfaisant
immédiatement et puis ça nous permet de
remettre ça de progresser de travailler
le truc d'apprendre et s'est donc séparé
retourner voir les vidéos il ya quand
même pas mal de conseils qui vont
s'appliquer là dans cette situation mais
lyon là non il ya des petites ips qui
permettent de gérer la situation au
mieux et qui s'appliqua à peu près tout
le monde
d'abord on supporte toujours moins bien
ce qu'on a l'impression de subir quand
on a l'impression que c'est imposé donc
approprié vous ce qui est en train de se
passer vous dit pas on m'a enfermée chez
moi de vous je reste chez moi pour
empêcher l'épidémie se propage et pour
sauver des vies il vous ça a dit vous
vous êtes en train de sauver des vies
dites vous que vous êtes un super héros
en fait vous sauver des vies super reste
à la maison
c'est cool ça
ensuite ne paniquez pas c'est vrai que
toutes ces mesures là ça peut paraître
flippant mais dites-vous juste deux
choses
déjà depuis le début de l'épidémie là on
voudrait jamais été plus en sécurité
qu'en ce moment vous êtes tranquilles
chez vous tout va bien et ensuite dites
vous que c'est en faisant ça qu'on va le
[ __ ] ce virus
parce que on va le [ __ ] nous sommes en
guerre non mais on n'est pas en guerre
on est en confinement solitaire c'est de
la santé publique
tu arrêtes un petit peu avec ça tu
chauffes il pleut tout le monde ce qu'il
faut aussi c'est de garder à peu près le
même rythme auquel vous êtes habitués en
temps normal psychologiquement c'est
important mais physiquement aussi
on sait qu'on tombe plus facilement
malade quand on bouleverse son rythme
habituel et qui a des maladies qui ont
tendance à se déclencher plus facilement
comme la migraine par exemple mais c'est
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles on
est un peu plus souvent malades quand on
arrive en vacances donc si vous
travaillez de chez vous par exemple si
vous télétravail est bon et ben vous
pouvez gratter un petit peu de sommeil
parce que vous allez économiser sur
votre temps de transport donc pourquoi
pas mais mettez à réveille quand même
ensuite je sais que c'est très tentant
mais ne bossait pas en slip pas laver
sur votre canapé
je vous jure que je sais très très bien
à quel point c'est très très très
tentant je vous assure
prenez une douche avant d'y mettre déjà
bon ça va vous faire du bien ça va vous
réveiller et puis moi ne serait ce que
le fact ivement c'est toujours mieux
après habillez-vous alors
confortablement si vous voulez vous
n'êtes pas obligé de taper le costard
taraabt mai habillez-vous et puis
trouvez vous un coin de table et une
chaise pour travailler pour être
concentration et pour votre dos ce sera
beaucoup mieux que le canapé ou le lit
sackboy que ça qu une table une chaise
penser à faire des pauses aussi pour
aller aux toilettes pour manger
évidemment juste pour vous dégourdir les
jambes pour discuter un peu comme dans
une journée de dur normal et puis à la
fin de la journée quand c'est fini c'est
fini
l'idée c'est de fixer clairement les
moments où on travaille et de faire que
ça et les moments où on travaille plus
où on va les pauses et ne pas travailler
ne pas penser au boulot le temps pour
bien séparer les deux trucs et puis ça
devrait bien se passer
donc il ya une histoire de rythme à
avoir pas tout bouleversé par rapport à
d'habitude se laver et s'habiller alors
des horaires faire des trucs un petit
peu aux mêmes heures que d'habitude mais
même si vous télétravail est pas si vous
êtes au chômage technique par exemple ou
si vous êtes au chômage tout court il ya
un certain nombre de ces règles là qui
s'applique quand même le seul truc c'est
que à la place de côté il faut trouver
des trucs à faire idéalement trouvez
vous un truc constructif agraire il ya
peut-être quelque chose que vous avez
toujours eu envie de faire et vous avez
jamais eu tant vous avez chalet prix
tant le faire peut-être pourriez-vous
dessus maintenant un projet je sais pas
pour faire votre cv ou écrire quelque
chose ou apprendre quelque chose vous
avez sûrement plein d'idées
là vous avez beaucoup de temps vous
allez avoir beaucoup de temps à y
consacrer donc c'est peut-être le volant
après vous avez aussi le droit de vous
dire que c'est des vacances et je suis
personne tout rouge pareil si vous
n'êtes rien c'est que vous bossez
toujours de chez vous mais que vous êtes
tout le contraire de ce que j'ai dit
depuis le début
si vous qui voyez faites comme vous
voulez si vous vivez bien comme ça n'est
pas de patronne
après évidemment il va falloir s'occuper
aussi se distraire parce qu'on ne peut
plus sortir
alors bien évidemment on lâche d
enfoncer des portes ouvertes mais on est
les bouquins il ya les jeux vidéo il ya
les films d'ailleurs dans cette dernière
catégorie il ya plusieurs initiatives
qui pourraient vous intéresser par
exemple canal plus diffusé en clair
jusqu'à la fin
bon ça c'est plutôt cool et puis bon je
vous laisserai chercher parce que je
suis pas là pour faire de la pub mais il
ya deux trois autres sites aussi eux qui
ont eu des initiatives de petit peu
solidaires ce que je vous propose c'est
maintenant de partager dans les
commentaires vos bons plans
ce soit des conseils pour bien gérer le
confinement pour bien gérer le stress
pour bien gérer le télétravail quoi que
ce soit des bons plans pour s'occuper
des trucs cool à faire assez
n'hésitez pas à partager ça dans les
commentaires
on se serre les coudes en attendant de
pouvoir se serrer dans les bras est
juste le serrer les mains serrons nous
les coudes et commentaires évidemment on
n'oublie pas de souhaiter bon courage
aux gens qui ne sont pas confinés parce
qu'ils sont obligés d'aller travailler
dont beaucoup et puis on n'oublie pas de
dire merci
un grand grand merci à tout le personnel
soignant aux pompiers aux secouristes à
tous les membres du système de soins du
système de santé français qui en ce
moment sont en train de nous sauver la
mise donc merci merci et puis grand
grand courage à vous j'espère que jal
est venu aux questions les plus
importants sûrement pas et puis on a
d'autres qui vont se poser dans les
jours qui viennent
n'hésitez pas à me les poser aussi dans
les commentaires je viendrai jeter un
peu de temps en temps peut-être que je
referai une espèce de faq un petit peu
plus tard mais en attendant bas et et on
se retrouve très vite pour d'autres
vidéos en notre télé travail sur dtc
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et plus que
jamais prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]